matthieu delormeau on a une surprise
pour vous il y a quelqu'un qui compte
beaucoup pour l'émission pour touche pas
à mon poste qu'a souhaité vous faire une
énorme surprise
vous allez avoir une minute trente pour
trouver qui se cache derrière cette
personne vous pouvez lui poser des
questions et répondra par oui ou par non
regardez cette personne est là c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qu'on aime dans
l'émission allez-y préfecture a les yeux
pour lui poser des questions
alors j'imagine que c'est un homme oui
on est en écoute oui oui est ce que vous
êtes connu dans mon nom alors il à
olemps temps et on entend très mal parce
qu'en fait il est il à manger des chips
est ce que vous êtes un artiste non un
petit peu pour moi un petit peu un petit
peu là dessus c'est un artiste ou est-ce
que vous avez déjà fait de la télévision
non plus non plus tout j'ai déjà
rencontré
est ce que on se connaît torse ne ment
pas persuadé personnellement est ce que
vous vous m'aimez bien ne sais pas non
plus accès il vous aime assez oui
d'accord et est ce que vous même déjà
rencontré grâce à moi j'ai juste une
paix une question posée c'est une
question à toutes les personnes qui
travaillent sur l'émission ou les eaux
là on en est au niveau du son corps
comment se situe au niveau des usagers
sont comment elle a juste sur l'échelle
de richter
la même émission mais m'ont fait flipper
alors elle et d'autres questions valider
notre question est ce que vous êtes
jeune oui oui est ce que vous connaissez
quelqu'un dans l'émission non plus
est-ce que zelda la médecine ils n'ont
pas pour moi vous êtes un ami je vous
aime fort avant est ce que vous êtes fan
de l'émission
j'adore à vie qui vous aimez le plus
dans l'émission se compliquer annie
c'est compliqué c'est que c'est gilles
gare des halles et la baisse
à votre avis qui sait est ce que vous
l'avez trouvé où elle a trouvé les
séquelles que j'imite mettez nous y jean
piot ni tu crois et nous nous c'est une
question qu est ce qu est ce qu il
il adore camille combal d'abord oui
d'aucuns j'ai trouvé qui sait oui et
vous seriez tous il est le problème
c'est que lui il a un cerveau qui est
une arène
la loisne à 10 camille combal camille
combal un autre un autre j'en peux plus
de vous un indice au lieu de donner un
deuxième lot un masque tient qu'aux est
là dedans qu'est ce qu'un rouge à la
danse j'adore comme moi vous êtes
passionné de danse et vous faites des
chorégraphies exactement ils ont répété
qu'en ce qui la collègue
et le qatar ait quitté les bureaux
modernes de camille combal cessa de
vengeur masqué nu vous dites que ces
crédits which we à la saisie lucho
il est là il est avec nous alors
regardez ce que fait créer 800 parce que
dans un instant dans un instant matthieu
delormeau
on va voir un petit magnéto et je vais
vous dire ce que vous allez faire avec
crazy which shows puisqu'on a envie de
voir quand même une battle de danse
mathieu mathieu et mathieu mathieu match
on est venu de loin
mathieu crazy miccio est là et c'est un
amour de mec vraiment je l'aimais
énormément et merci à lui d'être venu
mais mathieu vous allez rejoindre crazy
which aux mêmes s'affaisser pas fait
muscu aujourd'hui vous allez vous mettre
vous allez vous m vous allez voir dans
l'instant vous allez revenir dans la
même tenue crédit which shows on mettra
pas longtemps à vous habiller et mathieu
vous ferez une battle de dance avec
crazy which shows ici même sur ce
plateau
ça c'est le clou du spectacle c'est la
fleuriste dans mon second c'est la
cerise dans le monde chéri oui monsieur
de la mort
matthieu delormeau et crazy crazy show
demandez vous
à côté
google était bien là oh là là les deux
allaient attaquer martine
en force de garde
les deux en même temps aller dans le
sens rennes
on dirait
ceux là
de là
c'est manqué
là tout le monde adore parce que les
mecs jovial et si quand même c'est un
bateau neuf
remonté avec ça et moi pas dire votre
prénom c'est ça vous a pas créé j'ai eu
une chose merci et merci continuâmes